[Music]
[Applause]
the American president is doomed a
little old man can barely move if he
moves too quick he'll topple just like
the Domino he's got that Sinister smile
and thinks he just might win the bet but
he's just hanging on oh well dangling
like hunt a cigarette hundred times with
the hookah pipe say
[Music]
[Applause]
walk like a Joe Biden
[Music]
[Applause]
and when he boards Air Force One he
spins around and he hits the floor he's
got the moves he hits the death pen he
hits some more all the dams are so sick
of Joe they really would like to see him
and he's
[Music]
in the DNC said
foreign
[Music]
walk like a Joe Biden
[Applause]
[Music]
let's change
ah oh that was a little hot a little hot
today uh glad to be with you it is it's
third it's the last day of the show on
well on YouTube and Rumble and of course
uh yeah not forever no it's a it's a
live show that's the best time to tune
just set your schedule back like when
you used to use the uh the the Guide TV
really my mom calls it TV guy she
reverses yeah she's French
the guy TV I'm like Mom whatever
so Monday through Friday 10 a.m Eastern
and it is free uh mug club or
lottery.com mug Club tomorrow you get to
watch the show and Nick depalo all the
other shows that are coming to the
network a lot to talk with you about uh
today you know
we always want to be one of those what's
going on right oh never mind something
on CNN it doesn't matter I saw a cop a
cop lights flashing I thought it was
yeah I thought it was for one of our
upcoming sketches
you have been warned yes indeed uh we're
going to be talking about quite a bit
today but we want to offer you some some
solutions and always you know when we
feel that we we have a platform and we
can help you uh avoid DC this weekend uh
because of the trans day of Vengeance
that is coming and there's been a lot of
rhetoric both sides accused the other
side of you know encouraging violence
using rhetoric and so that's the
question here today for you who do you
think is actually fermenting to use that
term violence uh and we'll lay out a
pretty not only compelling but alarming
case we've gone into some of the leftist
message boards uh followed some of their
threads of course we have some people in
their groups and social media so uh the
chatter is disconcerting we'll be
talking about that we'll be talking
about the NHL not bowing to the woke mob
who would have thought that Eastern
Europeans don't want to wear they don't
want to dress like I Dream of Jeannie at
the NHL playoffs credit to Nick depalo
for that reference uh and uh a fight you
saw this in Our House of Representatives
yeah with Jamal
admonish me right off the bat guys just
hit the admonish button I got his name
wrong and In My Head by the way I was
just saying don't say Jamal don't say
Jamal Jamal don't say Jamal don't say
wrong because that would be racist so
all morning I was saying Jesse
so uh we'll be talking about uh all of
that Gerald number two in your show you
have a you know one of your people
really liked your apologetics show we're
gonna do another one of those tomorrow
along with a wrap up how are you I'm
doing well sir how are you I'm good yeah
I'm good we're relaxed today like I mean
aside from the fact that you know we
might get uh we might get murdered on on
there I don't know but that would be
great for Ratings
just tune in and it's just my feet
dangling thank God that element's not
there and uh you know him you love them
and I think you guys got it done there
on your phone are you guys good yeah
yeah okay but I gotta take care of this
on our phone the Hodge twins you can
follow them at conservative twins Keith
and Kevin Hodge how are you guys doing
great yeah doing amazing yeah hanging in
there you know life's tough yeah is it
no being black and all you know I think
that I think that might might be a
little too far away from you I don't
know if your microphone why are you
looking at your mug sorry didn't hear
you
sorry right so early and by the way keep
your comments keep your comments
tasteful about the ladies that's right
we've seen the Bengals parody calm down
it's okay we understand that you are
lonely
so but this is look the day of vengeance
is what they're naming it they're
they're remember when they said they
just wanted when the LGBT it wasn't LGBT
it was just LGB they just wanted to get
married yes
way back in the day yeah you know then
it was don't be absurd no one's coming
for your kids we had transgender
officials on the show you can go back
2016. yeah they're like no that's a
straw man that's a straw man hey what do
you think happens when you
hypersexualize children and and change
them chemically from a very very young
age and give them the ability to consent
to procedures that will forever alter
[Music]
okay you didn't chemically do anything
no no it's sexualize my mind just seeing
a hot white chicken that's not nearly as
bad as I thought the story was going to
you it was pretty bad like you know a
third Uncle at a barbecue or something
yeah there's the magazine of
magazine hey speaking of which
it's time to go to our first watch and
react here we have women uh telling you
right this is kind of a trend noun by
Trend I mean uh
I don't know it's something that it's
just something that women do now I guess
this is the thing demanding that you
find them attractive and declaring that
they are attractive which Once Upon a
Time used to have to be you know Beauty
was in the eye of the beholder now it's
um sluttiness and hotness is in the eye
of uh me and my elevated uh lipid
profile and if you want to call me a hoe
that's fine I am a whole
[Music]
and we have the other clip there too
show me the other one I mean I mean the
Carrie's like I'm not gonna have no man
tell me what to wear I'm not gonna have
no man someone gonna put on my face
my how I feel about myself is what comes
first
well and I don't know if you've heard of
narcissistic personality disorder but
hey go love yourself on your own time
you don't need to have your your your
Patsy cuck Ed McMahon fat I love myself
you are correct
you don't need to finish the second half
of the phrase yeah if you're ahead of
your household appropriately you just
say take it off that's generally a crowd
pleaser just wear nothing but this is
where we are right now right women have
been told that they are per and you know
what you never hear men saying
I am perfect
I am exactly the way God made me fats I
am hot
sure I mean I had a woman say this one
time too say you know well the thing is
it was it's always been okay for men to
be fat and okay let me ask you where oh
Chris Farley uh Belushi John Candy they
weren't on the cover of play girl did
you notice they these men had to be
insanely funny and talented and so they
were judged on the content of well
really I should say their talents their
abilities or the content of their
character right but you're demanding
that we declare You Beautiful solely
based on your looks that's not what
happened with that guys do you see any
fat guys who are Beauty models out there
who are the test holidays of the world
it's you create a fake double standard
so that now you create an actual double
standard look you have the right to love
yourself I think you're lying and then
men have the right to not what do they
say if you got to say it out loud you
don't mean it yes exactly she's
repeating it to herself it's like a
monster walk around to Black projects
deeply deep inside they hate themselves
yeah it was still white
I'm serious I'm serious as a heart
attack if I'm a walk around that I
would man I would feel stupid really
yeah exactly I'm proud I mean if you
really believe that you don't have to
say it yeah yeah there you go yeah I
also don't know why you're proud to be
black you weren't you didn't do anything
for it you'd have to work for it yeah
I'm not proud to be white yeah same
sense no exactly that's what he says on
camera
what power
I know we we've put a we put a lid on
the burning crosses in the green room
but you can't that some of them squeak
through uh speaking of racially charged
look
in today's story of there's nothing like
perpetuating the original stereotype uh
representative Jamal Brown and you've
probably seen this Bowman Bowman Bowman
Brown's way more racist
and how you said it was the most racist
part
hey Jared's got a black boy
did play football so every now and then
he will be like let's get it done but
[Laughter]
Bowman I apologize let me make sure I
get this right so I say it once so that
you know that uh it's just a it's just a
slip it's Jamal Bowman of New York 16th
District there you go okay are you happy
now he screamed at Republican
representative Thomas Massey there was
political theater committed what could
be considered borderline assault but a
lot of you have seen this clip but you
may not know the history of Mr Bowman
which brings us to this week's
installment of what a piece of
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
all right and so before you even before
you watch all these let me ask you how
much do you know about uh Jamal Bowman
and you know are you uh his fan singular
uh let's see the clip to set this up
that has been going viral and then we
have some more context
[Music]
they're my gun found ers
carry guns
you guys
two more times lead to more death just
keep repeating the same phrase
[Music]
states that have open carry laws have
more debt in every school banks that
have open carry the laws have more
deaths are you listening to what I'm
saying and here's the thing
calm down brother everyone saw this
right and everyone thought it was bad
but when you see the full context it
gets even worse is
I don't know that seemed like it was
staged
and you know here's a good example of
racial differences like if you watch
like Italians or you watch like the way
they bust balls right I mean you better
be quick or someone's going to they're
going to insult your insults I do notice
that with a lot of this posturing with
those in the Africa they repeat the same
phrase yeah like what I don't what what
you're a yeah you a call me
a again you're a call me a
again you a call me a
again you a call me a again
when does this end you uh bet you
won't say it again call me
like what is that I don't know it's a
culture thing it's a black thing they
either do that or they keep clapping
their hands yeah then when you try to
ask them what what okay what
yeah and you know we have an ugly
stereotype for for black men black women
when we being angry we have propensity
for violence where did that come from
well we have stereotypes for a reason
what's this again this is the promise
right if he if you say look this is
incredibly Unbecoming it's incredibly
unprofessional oh what you're just
saying the black angry black man
stereotype now you have been racist
because you said all black men act this
way they don't that's just you you're a
piece of yeah I know it's amazing
to the the create these gun free zones
you've made everybody in that school
teaching students vulnerable yeah and he
made a valid argument there's been no
shooting in a school where they have
guns the teachers it's never happened
well he said he switched immediately to
open carry oh hold on he didn't say
anything about open carry yeah he just
said if you allow I'm assuming you would
want it in a teacher like environment
you want it to be concealed so it sure
has no by the way that's also a trick
because even very liberal states that
don't have concealed carry still have
open carry right there are states that
are far like in Michigan for example you
need a permit at least you did now it's
changing me with Governor Whitmer uh you
used to have to have a permit when I
lived in Michigan to conceal carry but
you could open carry without a permit
and a big reason for that is because
people are carrying if they're hunting
right and so you'd be breaking the law
all the time it's also why it usually
doesn't apply to long guns a lot of
people don't know that if you don't have
any kind of a permit and your state
doesn't allow open carry of a pistol
there are still many states that allow
open carrying of long guns and the same
reason they changed knife laws in
Michigan because you're bringing a
hunting knife with you right you have to
field dress a deer yeah they don't want
you to go to jail which actually I
appreciate because usually the
government is looking for any reason to
toss you in jail
but here's the thing uh with Bowman
right do I have that right yes
um we have a few things here that I want
to kind of lay the groundwork with uh
here he is lecturing while he talks
about deaths and we'll catch some of the
numbers there in New York right
um there are ways to prevent if we want
to talk about common ground okay we
should we should find some common
Grumble we need to find Common Ground as
I've said on Truth common ground and a
lie is still just that a lie so you
would think he wants to save children's
lives here he is lecturing you the
American public black white red yellow I
guess that song really needs to be
updated it does yeah Jesus loves all the
people but needs to use the right
pronouns uh
March 9th after the parents Bill of
Rights Act was passed in committed
and I just want to ask a simple question
why can't we leave trans people alone
they're not bothering anyone they want
to go to school they want to play sports
they want to hang out with their friends
they want to live their lives they want
to shoot schools let them live their
lives oh my God they want to play sports
yeah I know he left out a lot of content
we're saying the same thing like look
look if you want to do what you want in
your own time that's fine but trans men
want to want to compete and beat women
he's like they just want to compete and
be women
that I think you're hearing me I hear
you let them beat women
ain't bothered nobody
oh there's some guy bouncing some poor
broad's head off the cage like a
basketball yeah yeah that's some
progress
okay that's an outlier we have two now
yelling at another representative and
then we have him basically advocating
for of course you know uh and keep in
mind the context when he is saying that
he's arguing against right a bill that
would protect children when we talk
about that we talk about children
transitioning and here's something too
think about this before I move on this
is something that has definitely been
kind of on my mind and not as a
conspiracy theory but it is this perfect
sort of right now this this intersect of
uh horrible policies that expose your
children to not just being sexualized
but we have a problem with sex
trafficking okay let's be clear there
are more slaves than ever on the face of
the Earth right now a lot of them are
sex slips so what do you think happens
when you sexualize young children I
think it's 400 something thousand
children go missing in the United States
you have open borders where you have the
cartel trafficking in children right so
we have okay open borders that
encourages sex trafficking we have soft
on crime policies and so that encourages
people to commit crimes and kidnap now
we have children being sexualized at
drag shows and being told that they can
transition and make sexual decisions for
the rest of their life oh not to mention
in the background you were a crazy
conspiracy theorist but Jeffrey Epstein
had a sex Island where former presidents
would visit with great fervor hey hold
on are you starting to see how you're
not looking out for your kids
do you think all those things are
happenstance genuinely I want to know
below is it is it that crazy when people
they try and paint it as absurd if
conservatives point out they go you
believe there's some satanic cabal of
pedophiles no no we believe that through
a series of policies you've harbored the
sexualization and sexual abuse of
children and that is a line in the sand
for a lot of parents are you looking for
are you looking for some kind of a civil
war because this is how you get it this
is how you get it and I really hope that
that does not happen of course I'm not
advocating that but we'll get to it the
trans activists are no we definitely
understand why and I'll just add to that
they're sexualizing kids in schools yes
and anybody who tries to take
pornographic material and I'll say it
like because it is pornographic material
out of the schools gets labeled as a
bigot yeah like you're supposed to leave
porn in schools for the five-year-olds
yeah
black Force again but they want to dance
to Kill a Mockingbird that was Middle
Ground I don't know because that was
pornographic we all remember when uh
we'll remember it to Boo Radley's tree
when he was banging the maid
[Music]
all right so here is Bowman advocating
as well to keep Tick Tock also a place
where children are hyperly sexualized
happenstance in the United States why
the Hysteria
and the panic and the targeting of tick
tock
as we know Republicans in particular
have been sounding the alarm creating a
Red Scare around China in terms of tick
tock's behavior and its and its risk to
National Security
it poses about the same threat
it's like Facebook and Instagram and
YouTube and their posts
well I won't argue with you by the way
on on YouTube which is uh by the way
head on over to rumble and uh it's a
free month of mug Club at the end of
this month I think it's April 20th it
ends we do ask that you you know support
join up and of course if you see this
get hit which no doubt will in the show
when we go to the trans day of engines
this button
it means that the content is still
available on Rumble we will no longer we
will we we never did but now we're just
leaning into it we're not going to
self-censor for YouTube I didn't hear
that part in the middle of that when we
watched that clip before the Red Scare
of China and I was like I finished about
the red tide and he's still congested
you mean oh so China is not a threat
yeah all of a sudden are you serious how
could they be a threat when they're so
little
maybe we're talking about different
places don't forget about the damn
balloons and to have flying yeah
exactly and you know what they only
censor one type of citizen in the United
States we've had like three or four tick
tocks over millions of views millions of
followers and they keep denying us you
can't share no uh conservative
perspective but if you're liberal and
you're trans or you you enter that or
you're a black racist yeah you all over
Tick Tock I think China's China poison
our society actually no I think you're
absolutely right yeah it's it's
effectively uh an intellectual property
weapon is how it started now I think
it's just an actual weapon they've
weaponized the intellect of our children
first generation on record that we know
that will have a lower IQ than a
previous generation that is scary
[Music]
foreign
through sexualizing them and keeping
Tick Tock there uh great what are the
results here's a question for you what
are the results in his home state
well 20 20 257 children under the age of
18 were killed or wounded by gunfire
that's a 15 increase over 2021 and to be
clear a huge portion of that is gang
violence right just to be clear I don't
want to play their game but if you're
going to use if you're going to use
their numbers you have gang violence and
gun crime in your state which is
atypical well I'm just I'm curious
because they have some of the strictest
gun laws in the United States I thought
that if we had strict gun laws that
there would be no yeah you know I
understand shooting I understand yeah no
I do I do see your point the real
problem is no cash bail right the catch
and release of prisoners and how do I
know this they've said that criminals
have said that they will commit more
crimes if the consequences are lighter
and they've said that what scares them
most is knowing that there is a
homeowner with a gun on the other side
of that door this comes straight from
the asshole's mouths just to be clear so
here's Jamal's stance on no cash bail
your freedom should not be based on your
bank account uh we need to end cash Bill
no no okay I think I think this is a
misunderstanding it's not about your
bank account about the heinous violent
crime that you commit yes I guess he's
thinking white people commit and crowds
oh they got money get released so let's
just release everybody yeah exactly
gosh damn he's stupid talking about
let's go ahead now let's just gonna say
something braces
[Laughter]
representative Jamal I'm not gonna I'm
gonna get his last name wrong uh uh
after Roe v Wade was overturned he said
this is a dark date but today the
abortion rights in every state in the
country oh
this up I don't have this stat in front
of me but if I'm going by Road I
actually think there are more black
babies aborted in your state of New York
than born yeah I thought it was for the
kids yeah hey why do they use the term
Reproductive Rights yeah they're not
reproducing
foreign
[Music]
orakai helps with the algorithm because
there's no way they want you to see this
go to rumble yeah just go to rumble we
would love to see that number go down to
zero let's see if we can do it today
let's see if we can get YouTube as close
to zero as possible and raise it on
Rumble please it'd be a lot of fun
here's another note in 2020 uh 20 I was
about to say 20 20. that's the next
that's the next Blade Runner
uh New York's abortion rate yeah it was
twice the national average twice the
national average so that's the number
that I do but I'm pretty sure they're
actually more black babies were aborted
uh in in the state of New York then
actually do you have that number
you sound about as sure as is Jamal you
need to wait till you have the number
man
um we have an article on about about
black abortion rate I'm looking for the
number now in New York
uh abortions versus Birds was 136
thousand four and twenty six thousand uh
the births were 100 right 136 000 to 118
000. there you go is that the state of
New York so the answer is so uh yes yes
2012 and 2016 black mothers terminated
136 000 pregnancies
genocide but they're called Trend that's
transgender yeah yeah they'll call
something what has never happened right
there's never been a matter of policy or
targeting the execution of transgenders
they will call that genocide and say
that you are transphobic if you don't
agree actual eugenicist Margaret Sanger
who specifically targeted black
neighborhoods and said let's set up shop
there so we can have as many black
babies aborted as possible because you
believe they were a drain on society
you'll also be racist if you refer to
attempted genocide as actual genocide
yeah do you understand the rules
everyone clear yeah yeah we're good okay
crazy so you have let's look at Jamal
brown but let's get beyond the political
theater of repeating the same thing over
and over and over like it's some kind of
a tantric yoga Mantra Jamal Brown wants
to what keep Tick Tock here he doesn't
think it's a threat to kids he wants to
kill record children in the womb as a
matter of policy we've seen that through
results and he wants children to be
transitioned to be hypersexualized at a
young age and do nothing about gang
violence who by the way the rate I think
in New York I don't have the number here
but I'm pretty positive this is correct
I think it was one-third of violent
crimes were committed by um by violent
criminals who were currently on parole
or who were currently uh pardoned or
were out waiting awaiting trial yeah oh
one third of them hey seriously Common
Ground keep them in keep them in prison
if they're violent criminals especially
if you have an epidemic in your state of
violence but hey instead Jamal Brown
wants those Bowman son of a he wants
those Twitter clicks he wants the
YouTube and most of all he wants those
Tick-Tock views so this has been this
week's what a piece of thank you
[Music]
all right we're gonna move on to uh
Gerald and sports and we're going to be
talking about the trans day of Vengeance
but your your thoughts on Bowman well at
least he's saving the state tax money
for welfare and stuff well keeping the
black population down here okay all
right yeah that's you can't see yeah too
far right there yeah you're gonna have
to go to Ace you guys you gotta go Sam
we have it yeah I gotta go see him we
gotta go see that Jewish guy yeah HR
let's go go to HR we'll be right back go
let's go go go go
yes
[Music]
god
um reports gentlemen that uh you guys
have been acting a little rambunctious
around the office Bram boxes what the
hell does that mean I mean I think you
got to confuse with somebody else what
the hell are you talking about yeah well
um I had uh one of our co-workers tell
me Kevin that um
I'm sorry it's just that you gentlemen
look alike you look like I'll look alike
to you what that's what he implied did
he yeah you insinuated it no it's just
that you're serious right now so this is
a heart attack Sammy
I'm serious my nuts are black
what are you trying to say you guys are
identical you can't be serious come here
you hunky and the language
will not be tolerated man I'm tired of
these damn Jews man
you guys are twins
you what
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I want you all to be aware of the trans
Dave Vengeance that is that is coming
and unfortunately it's been removed so
if you don't see this on YouTube it's
been removed from Twitter as a matter of
policy we'll get into that but really do
stay safe and protect your family stay
away uh from really I would say big
cities in general uh this Saturday uh
it's unfortunate that it's come to that
but right now another story that is kind
of a win Silver Lining yeah I told you
this would happen with the NHL
hockey family a lot of NHL teams now are
reconsidering The Pride nights
oh
after there's been a string of really
like you know high profile players who
just who wouldn't take part and that
brings us to Gerald no Sports
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Gerald you know that I don't like sports
but you like hockey I thought I used to
follow hockey a lot right yeah you you
respect hockey yes okay as opposed to
soccer which you have no I respect
excellence and anything including um
acts of blatant homosexuality so
you are going to be a homosexual athlete
over overpaid homosexual athlete be the
best overly paid homosexual athlete in
the world in that sucker speaking of
homosexual athletes uh the the pride
thing has been a kind of a fixture in
the NFL since uh 28 I'm sorry in HL see
there I go going to my sport boy like
sorry NHL since 2018. you don't have to
admonish me for that it's a slow news
day guys so teams often wear jerseys you
know with like the the numbers that are
kind of rainbowed out or they the tape
on the the what is it the the hockey
stick you guys call it oh my God I look
like a dildo it's terrible could you
imagine Steve Steve Eiserman dressed
like he's a skittles commercial that's
not gonna happen right so but this year
a good thing this is this is a win for
concern derivatives right and this is
also a road map for people in the NBA in
the NFL and other you know Sports and
soccer that don't want to necessarily
associate with this they are actually
opting out of doing this right and it's
specific players doing it right so
Flyers defenseman Ivan provorov said he
did not participate because of his and
to be clear before just spoiler alert
this has affected those at the top of
the league oh this shows you that that
boycotts and shows you that standing in
your ground that's the only way to
bridge the gap of the disconnect between
the woke corporate overlords and then
the fans and the players so when people
say it doesn't do anything well it's not
true the NHL has proved positive yeah
absolutely and so he said I'm not doing
this because of my faith
I respect everybody and I respect
everybody's choices my choices to stay
true to myself and my religion
that's all I'm gonna say
how do you religious beliefs any like I
said that's all I'm gonna comment on
that
um if you have any hockey questions I
would like I would answer those
it's fair
um
Russian Orthodox
so look as a result of those comments
and his stance his uh Jersey uh then
proceeded to sell out right the one not
the regular the one not dressed up like
a Starbucks yeah exactly all right so
sharks goalie James Reimer actually
cited his religious beliefs for not
participating in the Sharks Pride night
as well here he is I've been a Christian
not just entitled but in how I choose to
live my life daily
I have a personal faith in Jesus Christ
who died on the cross for my sins and in
response asked me to love everyone and
um
[Music]
I have no hate in my heart for for
anyone I've always strived to treat
everyone with respect and and kindness I
see how nice that was he didn't have to
come out like forcefully against this he
just said hey here's why I'm not doing
this and I have love for these people I
don't have hate for anybody out here I'm
just not going to do this because of my
faith right and so there are a number of
other players and teams now are actually
considering scaling back or actually
starting to scale this back and say ah
this really isn't for us but the
Atlantic actually had an article that
said that Russian players are opposing
this due to their fears for their safety
and you know good old Russia that's
getting it by the way there could be a
little column a column I don't know how
many pro like trans children activists
there are in Russia but if they did
exist they still wouldn't be able to
speak out anyway I'm pretty sure they
don't exist yeah I'm pretty sure I mean
it'd be it'd be the exception
considering that they they stab
pedophiles 36 times in the back and then
listed as listed as a suicide
good enough
please save yourself in back 36 times
before digging your own Shallow Grave
I don't understand it but you know you
do you do so all these comments seem
pretty reasonable to me these are
players coming out and just saying hey
this is just this is against my faith
but here's the problem this is all based
on Christianity or maybe they're afraid
but like we said the Russian thing but
some commentators are actually saying
that those players if if they want they
can go back to the place that they came
from essentially can get on a plane any
day you want and go back
it's where he feels more comfortable
take less money
and get on with this life that way if
it's that problematic for him what would
he have to do that yeah because you
think it's not when we say when we talk
about people coming here who by the way
are not seeking Asylum they want all the
benefits this country you say well you
know what if you don't like the culture
you don't like the custom of this
country then maybe you should go back to
the country you were trying to escape in
this case he's saying this guy should go
he has a support he has the Mandate of
the masses of the fans it is being
thrust upon Him by elitist at the top of
the league who by the way if you think
that the NHL if you think that hockey if
you are running this right if you're a
commissioner and you think that the
lgbtqaaip jerseys are going to be an
easy sell to a bunch of Eastern
Europeans many of whom still think
wearing helmets are gay
you're out of touch yeah you're out of
touch and it's unnecessary why do you
need to have rainbow colored numbers and
like are are gays not visible right now
do we really need to highlight
homosexuality right now to make sure
that there's visibility and that they
feel seen and there's inclusion are you
kidding me trans visibility it's what do
you think you're wearing the cloak from
Harry Potter we can all tell yeah
exactly well look make sure you download
the rumble app that's the only way to
make sure that we absolutely 100 the
actually notifications yeah
notifications work on the rumble app
great way to do it so make sure you go
to the app store right now that I'd be
very surprised if this show stays on
YouTube I doubt it will but look the NHL
commissioner kind of in response to this
Gary Bettman he spoke about potentially
ending Pride night so this is this is
the Silver Lining you guys push back a
little bit you make a little bit of
noise in a nice win some fun way and all
of a sudden here's his quote this is one
issue where players for a variety of
reasons may not feel comfortable wearing
the uniform as a form of endorsement
well of course they don't right you're
forcing something on them right now how
about this I I got an idea for you if
you want to see what people think of
this why don't we come up with a
Christian theme tonight where all the
uniforms have crosses on them and then
if somebody is Muslim and they say hey I
don't want to wear this you tell them to
go back to where they came from so that
they can play Hot they don't play hockey
in Saudi Arabia
maybe somewhere in like Abu Dhabi and
the ski hills
that's the same kind of thing like in
sports we don't need this yeah what we
need right now especially is a
separation something that we can go into
and just disconnect from all the crap
that's going on please don't infect it
like the NBA in the NFL the NFL tried to
do this as well they tried to do a ton
of stuff with black lives matter and it
absolutely backfired not saying the
national anthem absolutely backfired
right everybody started pulling away no
kidding it didn't backfire enough though
if you have too many you have too many
americ no now you still now the ratings
kind of creep back up and there are too
many Americans you see this in Michigan
that's what I'm saying like they ended a
lot of that stuff and so people came
back they kind of did but the problem is
it's still the same it's still the same
heads of the companies and so they have
so many people like right now in
Michigan your gun rights are are being
eroded and Michigan has a very very
strong Outdoors culture but then you get
a lot of these thuds we're saying well
it won't affect my hunting rifle won't
affect my shotgun right they don't
because it's I gotta go have my beer and
watch my sports ball and then they go
home and watch and then all of a sudden
it affects them and why didn't anyone
tell me the commies were coming well
look here here it is you want to keep
supporting these organizations who by
the way they're no longer looking out
here's what's happened too this is the
problem with with
um and I'm a free enterpriser do not get
me wrong but the greed combined with
International markets now they are no
longer uh they have no longer an
investment I guess in serving the
American public but it's all about
trying to reach International markets
like with basketball right they've been
more effective in making some inroads in
China so now you have an organization
right that was thrust into the public
eye by the United States buyer Ingenuity
by our ability to uh you know procure
the best athletes create an Elite Talent
pool and then they go okay but you know
what we could make we're making billions
we're making billions but we want to
make more more billions okay China so
now that's compromise the same thing
with film oh it's terrible in film
that's the case study on this because
they've been doing this for a long time
and now you get a movie like top gun
Maverick that comes out and all of a
sudden it's making news because it's
patriotic to some degree yeah right and
you're like oh wow that's a refreshing
thing and it does incredibly well at the
box office I don't know how it did in
China but I would imagine that you know
the the Chinese population they like
seeing a movie star you know with a
height that they can claim as their own
how tall is he like five six fella
I don't know apparently L Ron Hubbard
did not smile upon your height Tom
Cruise better get those Seton levels
checked no I think you're right this is
a win uh to a degree but you got to stay
on it because do you ever wonder like
when Amazon has a commercial with a
broad with a mustache when you see
Hershey's having a transgender you go
hold on a second hold on a second this
is not something that people have been
demanding there is a disconnect there
are more of you than them that's why
they get rid of the dislike button
that's why they remove content that they
don't agree with that's why Rumble is so
heartening to all this because you can
go you can actually see the numbers you
can see the interactions when things
aren't throttled they want you to feel
isolated and they have
[Music]
thank you
for the social credit scoring the ESG I
forget the actual things ESG when you
look at what's happening with these
corporations it's the boards just like
comedy right now is not written for you
that's why it's often so bad it's
written for the writer's room it's
written for the ivy Leaguers who've
never actually taken the stage that's
why you feel as though there's a
disconnect between you and the sports
leagues between you and the
entertainment media industrial complex
and it's by Design but there's an
opportunity with that because they are
overreaching in just one thing do not
allow yourself to feel isolated there
are more of you than them if one side
cannot have transparency and one side
your side our side demands it that tells
you that they don't want to engage
foreign
[Music]
with this crap right this has been
Gerald no Sports
wide open three stars
[Music]
all right uh please oh you know what
we're going to get here to the trans day
of Vengeance story so uh let me just
I'll plug this so that way in a couple
of seconds head from YouTube to rumble
because I I think we're going to have to
dump a lot of this which sucks because
you might actually be in physical danger
just to be clear we still just want your
YouTube number to go down yeah we do
want it to go down but genuinely I think
it's something that's important to
discuss you could be in physical danger
and YouTube probably won't allow us to
discuss it anyway so before we get to
that as you guys migrate over uh do
subscribe to the audio on Spotify on
Apple on Android on Google Play because
we found like 600 Old audio commercials
from when this program was on radio and
uh we are now you only get it on Friday
if you're on audio because they're only
audio commercials there's no visual
component if you subscribe and listen on
audio get like an hour show for the next
two Fridays and the rest of them the
catalog will be on mug club like 100 of
them but they can't all be gems here is
uh the Lost Tapes or just a taste but
we're gonna move on here there's a
problem with his
this is the most incredible thing
horse
what the ing
frankly the Japanese they take my calls
here I swear that gorilla reminds me of
my old college roommate it's it's
uncannon damage Jasper just do the lines
no no no no really it'd be great if we
could do a like a side by side and just
bring in don't say it so subscribe to
audio to get that tomorrow uh we didn't
know what to do with it we're like do we
just want to upload some of these we're
like we have to do it in installments so
okay getting to the uh trans uh and if
you hit the like button whatever you
want to do there on YouTube smash oh
smash the rumble button actually the
best thing to do
before we go into the trans day of
Vengeance and again I'm just trying to
make sure that I don't who cares you
know what yeah let's just go Full
Throttle just I want it to be just like
what is it to uh was it Total Recall
we're just gonna go right into it do it
you know the lady with the three breasts
was it three breaths yeah she had three
three which really shouldn't be all that
shocking it's simple math
wait what three breasts three three
boobs are better than two
so before we get to the trans day of
engines in look behind you the slippery
slope we warned you right uh seven women
you were told this would never happen
remember like so you think some guy's
just gonna fake like he's a woman to get
into women-only spaces
okay seven women sued a Wyoming
anniversary uh Wyoming University
sorority say that three times fast I'm
not giving anyone who wants to can do it
I'm not going to
for admitting a trans woman uh Artemis
Langford Smith into Kappa Kappa Gamma
and the lawsuit claims that Langford had
a Tinder profile to meet women and the
primaries in their complaining is that
this transgender individual had an
erection visible through his leggings oh
wow yes so this is an actual lawsuit all
references are available at light with
credit.com and we actually obtained
exclusive footage of oh yeah the
sorority uh the the perpetrator
thank you
that was just kind of to clear the
palette all right I just have to say
something here a dark room this guy must
have been packing some heat if it was a
visible erection through his leggings in
a dark room and he's in the corner while
he also staged a fake haunted house and
told him it was a bowl of spaghetti and
put their hands like grapes yeah it's a
bowl of worms one worm
all right so this this is something now
um and it's been uh removed or people
have been removed on Twitter for posting
it and I understand it
but you know understand the context same
thing I understand with the manifesto I
actually am curious to see what you guys
think about releasing the manifesto uh
you can comment below because I
understand that you don't want to
inspire copycats which is why we
generally have a policy of not releasing
it here's the problem there are already
copycats there are already people who
are galvanized uh in the trans Community
who believe that there's a genocide
which is a complete total fabrication
it's yet another delusion and so at this
point I think the people who need to
protect themselves need to be armed with
the information of you know
understanding uh what it is that they're
actually facing so in this scenario I
think actually the manifesto is is
appropriate because yeah or at least
telling I mean you can without even
releasing the manifesto you can say like
yes we read through it and yes the
church was a Target because they were
Christians and he felt like all of that
can just be said no no motive
take a stab at it uh so the trans day of
vengeance is something that's coming up
by the way um this is something uh that
has been going on for a while and let me
just my question to you is who is
actually
um fermenting violence right so the left
has made this claim that it's the right
so first let me start this with uh the
daily mail yesterday insinuated that the
Nashville Shooters parents were to blame
the headline read that Nashville math
school shooter Audrey Hale was rejected
by her Christian parents who couldn't
accept that she was gay and trans and
this is part of a larger Trend that we
see right this is a claim let's bring
this up a claim from the left and then
I'm going to give you um what I would
present as uh my best case you may refer
to it as irrefutable evidence
so the claim is at the right uses
rhetoric to inspire violence here's uh
our Prof well this is all our favorite
googly congresswoman yeah despite
inspiring a bomb threat
so the right wing incitement of violence
against trans Americans in this country
because they cannot
let go of this obsession
with fixating violence and inciting
violence against trans and LGBT in
addition to immigrants in addition to
women of color this is a party that
cannot pick on anyone their own side
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
right the claim is that it's the right
okay the leftist media is the one
pushing for violence I would argue and
they're doing it consistently uh in a
way that frankly I'm kind of surprised
is so blatant so let me read you a few
headlines here all references are
available at lottery.com here's one
following the Nashville shooting let's
go to vice vice the right is using the
Nashville shooting to declare war on
trans people oh boy here's another one
from New Republic Republicans push
dangerous anti-trans rhetoric after
Nashville uh Nashville Nashville school
shooting here's from Washington Post
Nashville shooting exploited by right to
escalate
anti-trans rhetoric now let me ask you
this too this is Washington Post right
this is vice take what they tell you is
911 the sequel 911 harder right January
6th and they tell you that's the worst
day when people were actually uh
promoting January 6 before that did
anyone was it promoted as storm the
capital and commit crimes or was it a
protest was it a protest a protest of
people which is what you should do in a
Democratic Society they weren't burning
down a church like happened only several
weeks earlier they weren't burning down
cities but I'm not just talking about
the actions I'm talking about the
rhetoric the rhetoric was let's join and
let's make our voices heard now let's
compare that again keeping in mind the
inspiration from all of these mainstream
media outlets and these are large media
Outlets uh the trans radical activist
Network Tran is the acronym it's like a
bill I guess at that point
um they're continuing on with and this
is why I say you don't need to don't
soften yourself when people say we need
to bring the temperature down notice
since the shooting
they've only turned the temperature up
on the left right you say hey I don't
care what anyone wants to do in their
own house uh or what they want to do if
they're an adult and how they want to
identify it but you say that all the
time let me ask you this and this is a
genuine question comment below and we'll
go maybe when we go to chat and I'll
take some of your responses when someone
is a radical gender activist and it is
very new and it is radical do they
preface it with and I know that you know
uh uh Christians Muslims really people
of all face of all monotheistic Faith
since the beginning of time and all
doctors up until the year 2004 obviously
believe that there were only male and
female and I understand that that's all
the Science Biology that existed for a
very long time and so I understand
[Music]
thank you
the trans day of Vengeance and activist
demonstration in support of the
transgender Community will proceed as
planned despite widespread backlash
after a mass shooting in Nashville
Tennessee the trans radical activist
Network announced it would push forward
with the demonstrations which are set to
take place in Washington DC from Friday
to Sunday
wait a minute there was just a mass
shooting involving a transgender
shouldn't you delay this and maybe
change the title of this little protest
that you're having they actually changed
it from trans day of visit trans day of
visibility to Vengeance to Vengeance so
this was actually they changed it to
what they thought was a better choice
well but but don't worry because they
when they said Vengeance they didn't
actually mean Vengeance right so that
that's where you know that's our fault
for not understanding which by the way
look at Gerald's shirt that's why we
have the fight like hell shirts right
you can get them at the Crowder shop and
you don't have to if you don't want to
we've made it available because it is a
rally incredible they try to say that
Donald Trump said you know fight like
fight like hell for your country right
people said oh that is that is that is
inspiring violence that's a call to
violence directly that is an expression
that people have used and we had a
montage of all kinds of different people
using it in the Senate could you imagine
Trump saying David yes oh God
Vengeance Mike Pence's day Adventures
Stormy Daniels I will have Vengeance I
will have Vengeance on that horse-faced
but it seems like Father Time had
Vengeance on her face isn't that right
pulled the ripcord on the
that's exactly what he would say
she is a menopause life raft folks and
it has a leak it has a leak doesn't it
but
if statement don't worry even though the
title is Vengeance and even though
people have been encouraging violence it
will be peaceful yeah good yeah just
take it from Al-Qaeda when are those
people are over peaceful yeah exactly at
the very least they're histrionic yeah
this protest is about Unity not inciting
violence Tran does not encourage
violence and it is not welcomed at this
event liar um
at the same time the post encourages
protesters to wear a mask again this is
side
that's good they want to match they just
want to be safe you know from code yeah
they don't want to hide their face
they're not going to commit crimes
anything it's not the hard to say
something yeah yeah exactly maybe it's
the monkey pox so making a comeback yeah
exactly there was an advocate commenting
on this on Twitter and I didn't pull the
tweet for the show I will next time but
they said if you are going to go and
commit violence please remove any of the
uh pronouns from your profile or LGBT
you anything we don't need that kind of
exposure right now and it was the
comment that somebody was like shouldn't
you be saying don't go commit violence
right not if you're going to commit
violence cover Your Tracks so they don't
blame this community
when one side demands transparency now
you may not and there's a conversation
to be had about at what point you know
for example on Twitter or on Facebook
would be considered a call to violence
right that's as far as I'm concerned it
should be the law not hate speech right
but you have the right thing you have to
allow all points of view on these
platforms and when they try and
Galvanize their base they want to get on
Twitter they want to get on YouTube they
want to get on Facebook they want to
reach as many people as possible even if
you look at what happened with the cap
little right 911 times 2 9 11 harder
this is 9 11 another day die again
tomorrow 9 11 whatever it is 911 are
forever that's what they believe you
know January 6th they want to reach as
many people as possible whereas you see
people on the left what they do they say
wear a mask right they don't want
transparency and they say by the way if
you're going to do what it is that we're
actually doing uh take this information
off of the big platforms let's take this
over to a message board yeah is are they
still up by the way on social media is
Tran can we confirm whether the social
media platforms the group may be up but
they were uh they were Banning uh tweets
for posting it because it is it is a
call to violence and so I don't think
that Twitter was saying hey we're
Banning you because you're pointing you
know I think they're saying hey this is
a call to violence we just don't want to
amplify it so to some degree and I
understand that what they're trying to
do the the problem with that is that it
basically hides the fact that hey we're
pointing out like Andy no did it
Marjorie Taylor green did it right they
were saying hey this is going on make
sure and so people aren't allowed to
speak out on it so maybe what they can
do is say hey there's this trans thing
going on April 1st
foreign
let me go to the actual definition of
vengeance according to the dictionary
infliction of injury harm humiliation or
the like on a person by another who has
been harmed by that person violent
Revenge well that Webster patriarchy it
says violent
they meant peaceful yes the dictionary
is wrong they must have looked up the
antonym peaceful Revenge I'm not sure
how you get revenge peacefully but I'm
sure they'll figure out a way I would
not be surprised yeah I would not be
surprised if that definition has changed
oh yeah of course that's true especially
if something happened they're going to
change Vengeance no but I mean look
there's a violent response is not
necessary if you were Trans in this
country today you have more protection
than just about any other group just ask
gay people it pisses them off right
that's the reason Dave Chappelle did the
joke he did right is because that group
is like wait what all of a sudden you
can do everything that you want to do
right that's the whole point there is no
like if you're being boxed into a corner
backed into a corner like we talked
about the other day then yes sometimes
your only response can be to physically
fight like if people come to take my
children that example that you used
right what else am I supposed to do if
it's about changing their gender because
they happen to wear shoes that were
heels to school one day to kind of make
a joke yeah by the way you might not
want to buy those Judy garlands I'm not
I won't not anymore yeah I'll return
that but there's nobody right now out
there in this mass movement trying to
take away your ability your ability to
live your life the way you want to what
they're saying is you cannot sexualize
our children you cannot force these
things on us you cannot put girls in
danger because you're a man who now
identifies as a woman and wants to use
their I'll take it a step further I am
saying don't force me to engage in your
in your uh yeah I'm just not gonna I'm
not gonna do it I'll refer to you by
your legal name and I'm never you know
we don't go out and just look like Blair
white I'm probably gonna call you a
woman but you look like a clown I'm
probably gonna call you Bobo I don't
know like yeah Blair white goes to the
right bar pronoun would probably be fine
yeah exactly you know what every until
you put in Blair white level effort
don't ask us for no exactly Blair white
is committed and also very hey Blair
Works my kind of woman very nice that's
a damn good woman yeah I don't think you
know what you just said
one of the Brand's radical activists
Network Twitter is still up tweets are
protected what do you mean oh you could
protect it yeah I I get it you know what
protected means it means that they can
let you see them right if they want to
which means everybody that they say can
get in there can actually still see the
tweets take the account down yeah
exactly yeah yeah while you're at it
let's also do that Ayatollah Community
uh
should be on there it's an unpopular
opinion but you know I take the risks I
just heard it out there Sam's like yes
yes yes
finally yes exactly he's not a big fan
of Iran no so let me give you a few
examples of where these people might be
inspired to uh encourage you to commit
an act of violence which is Vengeance
anyone do not be anywhere near the area
of Washington DC or I would say major
cities you know they're saying Friday
through Sunday I'd be very careful I
would be vigilant uh so I would again
this is not a call to violence it's a
call to stay safe and avoid it okay
avoid it stay stay away from it on
Twitter let's look prominent leftists uh
insinuated not insinuated basically said
transphobes should be murdered so let's
look at uh Katie Hobbs press secretary
here posted a tweet insinuating that she
would quote shoot
transphobes geez trans pornography model
Tiffany Starr tweeted a picture of a
movie character holding guns with the
caption me when more trans women rise up
to stop fascists from taking away their
right to exist trans-terrorism Tennessee
hashtag stop fascism just also like do
these people no self-awareness that it's
like in poor taste a transgender
activist just murdered a bunch of
children can you just
[Music]
oh
foreign
Capital what happened now here's some
trans rights activists yesterday
storming the Kentucky capital
[Applause]
I think I just saw the devil yeah
because nothing legitimizes
[Music]
foreign
thank you
by hosting the day of Vengeance just so
you know they also raise money for
firearm training
um here is a trans radical activist
showing off his her their whatever guns
oh boy
[Music]
like to her
week
putting on the foil coach
I do like that they had a Lee shirt I
expect the next one would be an AK-47
with Lois written across it
oh my God this is crazy and here's
something too and you know what I've
made the link available so that all of
you can go and check out what it is that
when I say this when I say enemy your
enemy the enemy of a free people the
enemy of a non-violent people there's a
Fame a very popular uh leftist uh
message board uh the Democratic
Underground yeah so the link is right
there you guys can go check it out and
see what they don't moderate here right
when they accuse Reddit conservative of
being fascist go check out Democratic
Underground uh there is a thread there
and I think it's very telling highly
recommend you go and read it here are
some of the quotes most of you know that
I'm not a violent man but given the
circumstances with what with the re-pigs
wanting to wipe us out like the Nazis
attempted to do to the undesirables in
my honest opinion it's time to start
fighting back with every means available
someone responded Jefferson told us from
time to time the roots of the tree of
Liberty must be watered with the blood
of maggots that time's coming
go and check out the website and see
what they're doing see what they're
actively planning and I just I hope I
hope the FBI has us on a watch list as
opposed to uh moms at school board
meetings after their daughters have been
sexually assaulted in bathrooms just a
thought yeah I think right now they're
they're going after uh conservatives
that are posting this on social media to
make sure that they warn people about
what's going on they can't have that yes
exactly so those tweets are protected by
the way but Twitter is suspending
conservatives who are posting the trans
Dave Vengeance flyer like we said the
suspensions by the way include Margaret
Taylor green Andy Noe the unwelcome
podcast so they have been uh suspended
uh let me see the case of unwelcome
um what we have we have this tweet was
posted before the Nashville shooting
even yeah that's right about the trans
day of engine so in other words imagine
this trying to warn people hey there
might be some violence coming down the
pike because these people are saying
we're going to commit violence and then
big Tech says Ah can't warn people about
violence that's inspiring violence and
then six people are shot including
children yeah absolutely we actually
have a quote from one of the Twitter VPS
there just to make sure you guys
understand like we're not just saying
Twitter's pulling it down for this this
is their own yeah this is from uh Ella
Irwin Twitter VP of trust and safety
said the graphic was reported by a high
number of users across our platform
yesterday and yes I'm sure the timing of
that was due to heightened sensitivity
of the language given the tragic events
in Nashville it was posted before yes it
was posted before it was posted before
and this is why we cannot be beholden to
YouTube Facebook Twitter any of these
big Tech
[Music]
great work over there it's going to take
time though he's not going to be able to
clean up this process overnight and so
there are going to be things like this
that happen where you can't even get the
warning out to people you can't even get
it out to people that this is happening
and then I just is infuriating to see
that they haven't taken down that
account yeah the solution to this
problem is take down the account first
go after the reposters who are basically
saying hey be careful next and do it
with some kind of better plan than this
maybe just reach out to him and say hey
just don't share the the image right you
can warn people that this is coming but
just don't share the image we don't want
the flyer to make the rounds I don't
know there's got to be a better way than
just suspending every single account
that does this because you're right how
do you know to avoid DC on Saturday yeah
and this is a thing look this is this is
why we feel like a big weight has been
lifted off our shoulders and we are
incredibly grateful to be partnered with
Rumble because we would run into this in
the past like well I I I'm doing people
a disservice if I can't warn them about
this and we would have to have a
conversation yeah but then what happens
is you'll be removed from YouTube you'll
be removed from these platforms and you
won't be able to tell them anything for
two weeks you know I guess the lesser of
two evils is to sort of dance around it
but we don't have to do that anymore
when you're at the point where you're
forbidden from speaking truth that
platform ceases to be of any value the
relationship with YouTube for example I
hope to see that number go down to zero
and it go up uh on Rumble and by the way
it is a free month of mug club.com you
do not have to enter in your credit card
information get to watch for free
including tomorrow's show which will be
nowhere else uh the the issue here it's
it's the relationship with YouTube is
like this
and Facebook it's like let's say you're
in a marriage and you're going to
therapy okay and you you both
acknowledge okay that you have an issue
that you want to work out or couples
therapy whatever and you say okay we
have problems communicating all right
fine so let's go there and get better
communication okay fine and then you go
in and she says uh no I don't want to
talk about communication uh he actually
is uh uh he's a bestialist if that's a
term you go wait what what like well
that's not true and now all of a sudden
you're not you're gonna have a
productive conversation
you can't it's now based on a lie and by
the way you were lied to in order to be
lured into that room for therapy you
were lied to with the promise of being
able to discuss these issues open
dialogue right no gatekeeper section 230
to be lured over to YouTube which is
what created their Capital all the
eyeballs and years same thing with
Facebook same thing with Twitter and now
they've switched the game and you can't
have a productive conversation you
cannot even warn people there of
impending Violence by their own
definition
the purpose at that point there needs to
be a Migration by the way it's a live
show Monday through Friday only on mug
Club on Friday at 10 A.M Eastern we're
about to go with the Hodge twins follow
them at conservative twins again to my
club it's chat Thursday we also have an
entire segment here on Macaulay Culkin's
brother Rory Culkin yeah showing his
wiener with strawberries and
that's funny I have an update on the Q
Anon Shaman that we'll do over there too
so if you're on YouTube right now we
have an update I will you won't hear it
is this a tease yes there's a real
update on Q a date all right please tell
me like he I won't say it we'll just say
it on all right
we will see you tomorrow if you are not
here on YouTube please head on over
smash the rumble button and we are going
to discuss some issues that we
absolutely cannot just you know what you
do you know that YouTube piss off
foreign